we have a voicemail number which you can
call anytime that number is
219 to david p here is a good question
but from someone who sounds maybe a
little confused about the numbers take a
listen to this
hey um my name is billy i call from
middle of new jersey
i had a thought about the election if
you
think about all the info and everybody
who's voting
what's the best possible voter number
count going into this election i'm
thinking
for joe biden to win no matter what it's
got to be 120 million votes
and that would probably leave donald
trump to 40 to 50
mil that's my thought on him
best possible chance of winning no
matter what okay so listen you you are
correctly identifying that joe biden
needs a big margin of victory in the
popular vote to
safely if you account for everything if
you account for
the way in which the system is lopsided
to help republicans that's the electoral
college system to account for
uh voter fraud that uh not
voter suppression rather um and election
fraud
and all of those other things yes joe
biden needs a nice healthy
popular vote margin but 120 million to
40 million is not gonna happen that
that's just not first of all i don't
even think that that many people are
going to vote
um last election it was both hillary and
trump had in the 60 million range i
don't remember if it was 63 to 60 or
64 to 62 something like that uh what
you're suggesting
120 million to 40 million that's like a
a three to one victory for joe biden joe
biden's not gonna win 75 to 25
okay i think that if you look at the
data
and nate silver has put this data out if
joe biden can win by
four his chances of winning the
electoral college are
very very good if joe biden were to win
by five or six in the popular vote he
would almost certainly win the electoral
college so
you're thinking in the right terms the
numbers are a little bit
out there but the point is we need
every vote we need to run up the score
in every state assume nothing concede
nothing and if we do that you could have
joe biden
in the high 60 millions and donald trump
in the low 60 millions it is certainly
possible
we have a great bonus show planned for
you today uh donald trump's former
campaign manager has been hospitalized
it's a very sad story actually
we're going to talk about it there is a
cult leader who claims to be the
reincarnation of jesus i've actually
seen
a documentary about him he's been
arrested in russia we'll tell you why
and also
major breaking news on time travel
although i guess if time travel were
possible
somebody would have already come back
and done the bonus show already and
you'd know by now
no i'm kidding but um major news about
paradox
free time travel which i am very much
looking forward to discussing with you
on the bonus show get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at joinpacman.com
and don't forget tomorrow night 8 30 p.m
eastern
5 30 p.m pacific debate number one
between donald trump and joe biden